في هان يونس، أصابت قذائف مدفعية من غزة
الطوابق العليا
لمقر جمعية الهلال الأحمر الفلسطيني،
وهناك تقارير عن عدة جرحى بين
النازحين الذين يحتمون في ذلك
المبنى، انضموا إلي الآن لمناقشة ذلك
والمزيد من رالا في الضفة الغربية،
المتحدث باسم نيبال فارا.  بالنسبة
لجمعية الهلال الأحمر الفلسطيني، أشكركم جزيل الشكر على
الوقت الذي أمضيتموه للانضمام إلينا
هذا الصباح، أنا وفريقي،
نأسف بشدة لسماع نبأ الغارة على
مقركم. ما الذي يمكنك أن تخبرنا به أكثر
عن ظروف ذلك إذا
كان هناك أي شيء؟  إصابات ونسمع أيضًا
عن قصف على أحد
مستشفياتكم
أيضًا، صباح الخير، شكرًا لاستضافتي في وقت
مبكر منذ ساعة تقريبًا،
قصف مدفعي يستهدف الطوابق العليا
لمقر الهلال الأحمر الفلسطيني في
حونس، مما أدى إلى سقوط عدد من الضحايا
أه إصابات بين
النازحين لدينا داخل
مقرنا ومستشفى مكافحة غسيل الأموال أه
الذي بجوار
مقرنا حوالي 14 ألف مدني يحتمون
داخل مرافقنا
وهؤلاء ليس لديهم مكان يذهبون إليه
ظنوا أنهم سيكونون فيه
مكان آمن لكن للأسف يبدو أن
الأمر ليس كذلك هذا ليس
الاستهداف الأول وحتى قبل يومين
تم استهداف طفل عمره 13 سنة أه صبي من
قبل
طائرة إسرائيلية أه بذخيرة حية
طائرة بدون طيار مما أدى إلى مقتل
الصبي للأسف كما
سلطت الضوء للتو في التقرير لا يوجد
مكان آمن في غزة والناس
يبحثون يائسين عن مكان آمن للذهاب إليه في
الماضي أه يومين أه كان هناك
قصف شديد للغاية في منطقة
وسط غزة سواء في البلح أو  قام
الهلال الأحمر الفلسطيني
بإجلاء العشرات من الأشخاص الذين
استشهدوا وأصيب العشرات
جراء القصف المكثف في مخيم المغازي للاجئين، ولا
يزال الناس لا يعرفون إلى أين يذهبون، وما
زالوا تحت التهديد المستمر
بالقصف على منازلهم، كما أنه
مجرد دائرة مستمرة تنتقل من
مكان إلى آخر في حين لا يوجد
مكان آمن، كما تم قصف الأشخاص الذين تم إجلاؤهم إلى
رفح حيث تجبر إسرائيل الناس على
الذهاب إليه، في رفح أيضًا